ام
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله اعلنت هيئه علماء
المسلمين في لبنان التوصل لاتفاق لوقف
اطلاق النار بين الجيش اللبناني ومجموعات
سوريه مسلحه في عرسال لمده اربع وعشرين
ساعه ويسمح الاتفاق بادخال مساعدات
انسانيه الى هذه البلده وب اجلاء الجرحى
الذين سقطوا خلال الاشتباكات التي شهدتها
في الايام الماضيه
نتوقف مع هذا الخبر لنناقشه في محورين
ما هي احتمالات نجاح جهود الوساطه في
ايجاد مخرج ينهي الازمه ويحقق الاستقرار
في منطقه عرسال وما هي انعكاسات استمرار
هذه الازمه على الوضع الداخلي اللبناني
اتفاق وقف اطلاق النار في عرسال يوم واحد
يبدو خطوه اوليه قد تتلوها خطوات اخرى على
طريق محاوله تطويق تداعيات الاشتباكات
التي
تفجرت خلال الايام الماضيه بين مسلحين
سوريين وقوات الجيش اللبناني وتم اعلان
الاتفاق بعد اجتماع رئيس الوزراء اللبناني
تمام سلام مع وفد هيئه علماء المسلمين
الذي دخل منطقه عرسال وبعد اتصال قائد
الجيش اللبناني وكانت الهيئه قد اتهمت من
سمتهم متضررين من وساطتها بالسعي لتعطيلها
اولى ثمار الوساطه في احداث رسائل اتفاق
لوقف اطلاق النار لمده اربع وعشرين ساعه
يتيح ايضا دخول مساعدات انسانيه الى
البلده و اجلاء الجرحى منها سبق الاتفاق ب
خليل اخراج المسلحين السوريين عن ثلاثه من
بين عشرات من قوى الامن الداخلي اللبناني
يحتجزونهم وقدموا الامر كبادره حسن النيه
تبدو نقطه تسجل لهيئه علماء المسلمين في
لبنان التي لم تقعدها عن اكمال وساطتها
حادثه اطلاق النار على وفد ها واصابه
بعضهم فقد مضت في عرض مبادرتها التي تتضمن
تسليم ثلاثه محتجزين من الجيش يليه انسحاب
المسلحين الى جنود القلمون وفي المرحله
التاليه تشكل لجنه من المسلحين و اهالي
عرسال وهيئه العلماء للتوافق على تسليم
باقي اسرى الجيش والمعتقلين لدى القوى
الامنيه لا يعرف ما اذا كانت الهدنه
المعلنه تعني بالضروره قبول الجانب
اللبناني بالمبادره باكملها وهو ما يطرح
تساؤلات حول ما لا ت جهود الوساطه الساعيه
لوقف الاشتباكات التي اوقعت عشرات القتلى
والجرحى في صفوف الجيش والمدنيين
انها ازمه يخشى من تمدد رقعتها لا سيما
بعدما تردد صداها في مدينه طرابلس
الشماليه المضطربه في الاساس وثمه خشيه
اكبر من ان تعمق احداث ارسال خلافات
اللبنانيين السياسيه منها والطائفيه والتي
تصاعدت بفعل الثوره السوريه
في الظاهر تجمع مواقف الطبقه السياسيه
اللبنانيه على دعم الجيش وتوجهات حكومه
تمام سلام القائله انه لا حلول سياسيه ان
مع من تصفهم بالتكفيريين حتى رئيس الحكومه
الاسبق سعد الحريري يتحدث عن دعم الجيش
اللبناني في معركته ضد ما سماه الارهاب
والزمر المسلحه وذاك موقف قد يبدو متناغم
مع بيان حزب الله الذي يؤكد وقوفه صفا
واحدا مع الجيش في مواجهه ما يراه خطرا
يهدد وحده لبنان واستقراره غير ان من
الساسه في لبنان من يعتقد ان ما يحدث في
عرسال هي محاوله استدراج الجيش اللبناني
الى المواجهه من طرف النظام السوري
وحلفاءه اللبنانيين يظن هؤلاء ان تدخل حزب
الله في سوريا هو الذي اوجد الوضع الراهن
في عرسال عرفان التي تشهد اوضاع انسانيه
صعبه والقتال في البلده اضر كثيرا ب
مخيمات يعيش فيها كثيرون من بين عشرات
الالاف من اللاجئين السوريين
ارسال التي فتحت لهم قلبها لم تعد امنه
لهم ولا لابنائها
ولمناقشه هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا من بيروت
رشيد درباس وزير الشؤون الاجتماعيه
اللبناني و
داوود رمال الصحفي في جريده السفير
اللبنانيه ومن منطقه سهل البقاع الشيخ
خليل ليس مفتي زحله والبقاع
مرحبا بضيفنا الكرام سيد الوزير الان
توصلتم الى هدنه انسانيه مدتها 24 ساعه
ولكن ماذا بعد هذه الهدنه
هناك ضمانات بانها تتكرر هذه الشبكات بعد
اربعه وعشرين بعد اربع وعشرين ساعه
لا اظن ان الاحداث التي وقعت في عرسال كان
المقصود فيها احتلال هذه البلده
فمن الناحيه العمليه
يوجد في هذه البلده اكثر من ثمانين الف
لاجئ السوري
يشكلون ضعفي عدد سكانها
ولكن الذي جرى هو عمل مفتعل من اجل تعميمه
على لبنان كله
مهما كانت الدعاوى التي اطلقت فوق هذا
العمل
ولكن الذي حدث ان
هذا العمل لقي استنكارا جماعيا من كل
اللبنانيين ومن كل الطوائف
وخاصه من الطائفه السنيه التي يجري الان
الافتراء عليها سواء باحتلال ارسال او ب
سقوط هذا العدد الكبير من ابنائها من
شهداء الجيش حيث نجد الاعلام السوداء
مرفوعه في تلك الكره حزنا على الشهداء
اظن ان الموقف السياسي الحازم من قبل
اللبنانيين الذي وقف بوجه هذه الظاهره
الاجراميه قد فشل الخطه وان كانت شرارتها
العسكريه مازالت مشتعله
الاتفاق
سالتك بشكل محدد عن هذه الهدنه هل هناك
ضمانات الا تعود الاشتباكات بعد اتهام
اقول لك هذه هذه الهدنه و بين مزدوجين
لانه لا مجال للاتفاق بين القوات المسلحه
والاصابات اقولها وقف النار هذا ربما كان
المقصود منه اتاحه الفرصه للمسلحين
للانسحاب من عرسال واذا امر مرغوب ومطلوب
فاذا حدث هذا تكون المساله قد انتهت عند
هذا الحد ونكون قد ما يرمي بامتحان ناجح
وهو ان هذه ال اه
المحاوله قد فشلت فشلا ذريعا
ماهي شروط المسلحين تفضل ماهي الشروط
المسلحين للانسحاب من ارسال ووقف اطلاق
النار
الان نحن المسلحون غير الجيش لا شروط لهم
ولا اثر لهم ولا قرار لهم ولا يسمع كلامهم
انما المطلوب ان ينسحبوا من ارض من ارسال
خارج حدود هذه البلده يعود الامن
والاستقرار اليها والحقيقه كان هؤلاء
استدرج استدرجوا الى هذا الموقع ل اه
انشاء معركه يعني تنتقل من قل مون من
القانون التي تصل الى ارساء ونرجو اولا
اهلنا في عرسال كانوا على وعي كامل على
وعي كامل بتجنب هذه الفتنه وعدم التجاوب
طبعا مع ال البندقيه الوافده وهم مع الجيش
قولا وعملا ول يعود الامن الى المنطقه على
ايه حال
هذه المنام اعلم انك للذين ربما شاركوا في
طرح بعض بنود هذه المبادره الذين تحدثوا
الى هؤلاء المسلحين ماذا قالوا لهم حينما
طلبوا منهم الانسحاب والخروج من الارسال
نحن على تواصل مع الداخل لا لا شروط
المسلح الا ان صاحب وانتهى الامر كل شيء
لا شرط له لانه وجوده غير طبيعي ليس وطن
وهذا وليس بلد هو للنازحين وليس للسلاح
وليس الاصطلاح وجوده طبيعي وخروج هو امر
طبيعي لامرين لسلامه المواطن وسلامه
النازحين السوريين لان كما تعلمون انه
باشارات الارهاب في تلك المنطقه ليس من
مصلحتهم ولا من مصلحه ال النازحين ان يكون
هنالك وجود عسكري اه ي يضر بالجميع وطبعا
التي استخدم الجيش الى هذه المنطقه و وجود
هذه البندقيه غير الشرعيه في مكانها غير
الشرعي اه السيد اولا هل من خشيه ان يتمدد
ما يجري الان في ارسال الى خارج عرسال الى
جوارها او الى اماكن ابعد في التراب
اللبناني
يعني لو قيده للمخطط الذي كان يعد
المسلحون الارهابيون ان ينجح اه اه وقد ا
فشله الجيش اللبناني عبر اعتقال
المدعو جمعه اما جمع وهو مخطط العماد جمعه
وهو محطه كان يعني الى احتلال ارسال
وجهودها وربطها بالداخل السوري في يعني
مناطق تواجد المسلحين داخل سوريا في عمليه
استباقيه قبل حلول فصل الشتاء لكي يكون
هؤلاء المسلحين ملاذ امن
واعلان دولتهم الشبيهه ب دويله الموصل
الجيش اللبناني افشل هذا المخطط صحيح ان
الضربه التي دفعها الجيش كبيره ولكن الوقت
هذا المخطط ان ينجح لك ان الشعب اللبناني
دفع ضريبه اما القول ب اه امكانيه تمدد اه
هذا الحدث اه الانساني الذي لا يعني هل
ارسال اه يعني من الناحيه العملانيه لان
التاريخ الاهالي اكثر معروف الوطنيه منذ
تاريخ الاحتلال الاسرائيلي معروفه ارسال
بمقاومتها للعدو معه في بناء هذا الوطن
وتضحياتها هذا ال هذا الحدث العسالي اعتقد
ان ال السلطه السياسيه اللبنانيه الممثله
بالحكومه اللبنانيه اه تداركت هذا الامر
من خلال الموقف الا جماعي الذي اتخذته
الحكومه وايضا الافرقاء السياسيين على
ضفتي الانقسام السياسي اللبناني في ثمان
واربعطاش اذار
تحسسوا خطوره هذا الامر وكانت لهم مواقف
معي ايضا تهدف الى تحصين الساحه الداخليه
اللبنانيه و اه بالاستناد الى اه ما لمسه
الافرقاء من هذا الاحتقان الشعبي العام
للجيش اللبناني في مواجهته ضد الارهاب
القائمه حاليا السيد الوزير هل من الوارد
ان اه توافق الحكومه على ان يطلق اه
المسلحون سراح جنود الجيش اللبناني وفي
نفس الوقت هي يسمح بادخال المساعدات
الانسانيه والطبيه الى ارسال على ان يكون
ربما هناك خطوات اخرى بعد ذلك قد يكون من
بينها اطلاق سراح بعض الذين تم اعتقالهم
من هذه الجماعات المسلحه
اولا الجيش اللبناني ليس على الدول الجيش
اللبناني وابن الشعب هو ابن ارسال وبقيه
البلدان طبيعه الحال اهم شيء اه يقوم به
الجيش اللبناني وحمايه هذه المدينه
وبالتالي سيسهل مرور ال اه المعونات
الغذائيه والطبيه الى هذه المدينه
المحاصره وال مخطوفه والتي جميل ها لانها
كانت اول من افضل ال النزوح السوري واعتقد
ان هؤلاء المسلحين قد اساء للشعب هم اكثر
من مساء الارسال ولك ان تعلم ان جميع
المخيمات التي توجد في قد احترقت بالكامل
وان ثمانين الفا من الاخوه السوريين اه ي
يفتون في العراق اه انا ارى الان ان الجيش
اللبناني سيسهل مرور هذه ال المعونات
وانني اعتقد ان هذا الامر لن يطول كثيرا
لان لم يعد امام المسلحين الا الانسحاب
كما قال سماحه المفتي الذي احييه على
موقفه وعلى رجاحه عقله وعلى صلابته و
توازنه الوطني
اقول ان ما يقوله سماحته هو صحيح تماما اه
لا افتروا على اه
على اهلكم اكثروا على لبنان ولكن خصوصا
بالانسحاب لا يمكن ان يتم الانسحاب دون
ترتيبات معينه
كيف يمكن ان تتم هذه الترتيبات دون حديثه
الى هؤلاء والتنسيق معهم ودون تقديم
ضمانات لهم بانهم ان خرجوا لن يكونوا
ربما
للقصف والتنكيل اذا ما عبروا الى الضفه
الاخرى الى خارج الحدود
الجواب على ذلك بسيط هل اتى به ضمن
ترتيبات معينه حتى يخرج من ترتيبات معينه
لكن الوضع يختلف
الجيش له كلمه شرف عندما يقول اوقفوا
اطلاق النار تمهيدا لانسحاب هم فانه لن
يطلق عليهم النار هم الذين تخلوا عن الشرف
وليس الجيش طيب س سيد اه اه رمال الشيخ
قبلان اه سؤالي حول هذه المبادره هل
ستستمرون انتم في المبادره هل ستس
تكملونها هل هناك من افكار جديده سيحملها
ان عاد وفد الوساطه الى الى هؤلاء
المسلحين
لاشك ان الانسحاب فيه مصلحه حتى ل هؤلاء
المسلحين لانه وجوده في هذه المنطقه غير
طبيعي ويعود عليهم بالدور الكبير ويعودوا
على الاخوه النازحين بالدوره الاكبر وهذا
الذي حصل في اليومين السابقين
لذلك الان من اتى بهم فلندخل بهذا القضايا
العسكريه ولكن دخوله كان خطا وخروجهم هو
الصواب الثواب لمصلحتهم ولمصلحه النازحين
ولمصلحه المواطنين في الارسال التي
احتضنت الاخوه النازحين السوريين ولا يجوز
ان تكافئ بما حصل على
من ابنائها هذا من ناحيه
على ايه حال
ان الناس ان مسلحين
سيخرجون
سيخرجون ويتركون الساحه لان لا مصلحه لهم
في بقاء بهذه المنطقه هل ستستمر الوسط لا
مصلحه لهم او لا من قريب ولا الشيخ
كان هذا مطلبهم ان ينسحبوا من قبل ان شاء
الله الوساطه ستستمر باذن الله والمعلومات
لدينا انه سينسحب في في الظلام حتى لا يرى
ولا يروا اين يذهبون الايام ان شاء الله
نعم لا شك به ليله الانسحاب هو هذا المقرر
لا عسكريون يعني يريدون ان يروا لا لا
يرون
الى المناطق التي اه قبل موافقه
لا لا شك انهم مطلوبون ان يسحبوا ايضا
وجودهم الغلط وجودهم كان فيه دخول مع
النازحين كان هو الخطا والسلام لهم
والنازحين ان يخرجوا من المنطقه وتبقى
المنطقه
والله هاي خطه عسكريه داخلي فيها هم
ينسحبون بطريقته كما دخلوا يخرجون على كل
حال سنناقش اه اه بعد فاصل قصير مشاهدينا
الكرام انعكاسات استمرار المواجهات بين
الجيش اللبناني ومسلحين سوريين في ارسال
على الوضع الداخلي في لبنان
ان تبقوا معنا
اهلا بكم من جديد مشاهدينا الكرام في هذه
الحلقه التي تناقش امكانات احتواء التوتر
بين الجيش اللبناني ومسلحين سوريين في
منطقه عرسال وتاثير استمراره على وضع
داخلي في لبنان نرحب بضيوفي من جديد
نتيجه الانقسام السياسي الحاصل في لبنان
الان بين اعضاء وراء اربعطاش اذار هل ما
يحصل في عرسال سيكون له الارتدادات او اي
ارتدادات سياسيه في الداخل اللبناني
وممكن ان يعمق هذه الازمه ام لربما قد
يكون الوضع اه ربما افضل بعد هذه الازمه
بحكم ان هناك تقارب في وجهات النظر بين
مختلف الفرقاء
اه اعتقد ان الاحتمال الثاني الذي اوردته
او ربطه حضرتك هو الاحتمال ال الاسهم كما
قلت ان هناك موقفا جماعي لكل الافرقاء
السياسيين على ضفتي الانقسام ولعل يعني من
نافل القول ان الاعتداء على الجيش
اللبناني من قبل المسلحين الغرباء في
منطقه ارسال عاد توحيد صفوف اه اه
اللبنانيين عاد توحيد موقف الافرقاء
السياسيين
والذي عبر عنه كما قلت في الحكومه
اللبنانيه ومن قبل القوى السياسيه الممثله
في لبنان لا اعتقد ان هناك خوفا على
الواقع اللبناني ولكن لابد من الاضاءه على
نقطه اساسيه مركزيه هي التي تتحكم بمسار
الاحداث في لبنان هناك يعني اه هناك
مجموعه دوليه اجتمعت في خمسه وعشرين ايلول
الفائت على هامش اعمال الامم المتحده في
نيويورك هذه المجموعه الدوليه اه افضت الى
خلاصات من هذه الخلافات الدعم الامني
والعسكري والاقتصادي والسياسي والدعم
لبنان ودعم استقرار لبنان امنيا وسياسيا
ترجمت هذه الخلاصات
بمؤتمر عموما لدعم الجيش اللبناني وكان من
نتيجتها ايضا الهبه السعوديه والتي هي
بقيمه ثلاثه
مليار دولار اعتقد انا اعتقد ان اه
الاحاطه الدوليه للبنان رسمت خطوطا حمراء
ما حدث في ارسال اه مثل تجاوزا لبعض هذه
الخطوط الحمراء وبالتالي الجهات التي تدعم
هؤلاء المسلحين يبدو ان هناك اتصالات
دوليه جرت ل اه اه منع تمادى اه هذه
الحاله خصوصا وان هناك اتفاقا غير معلنه
على اعتبار لبنان في ظل التوتر التوترات
المحيطه به ان في سوريا او في العراق او
في فلسطين هناك اتفاقا دوليا غير معلنه اه
باعتبار لبنان وضعا خاصا اه بمناى اه يعني
نسبيا اه عن تداعيات الاحداث المحيطه به
السيد الوزير هنا هناك الان نبره اه اه
واحده واحد تقريبا تتحدث بها الحكومه
واعضاء الحكومه في هذه الازمه ولكن السؤال
هل الامر اه ان هذه القوى السياسيه
المشكله للحكومه وال وال مختلف القوى
السياسيه في لبنان بدات تشعر بالخطر الذي
يتهدد الوطن وبالتالي يقتضي قد الامر وقفه
رجل واحد بين كل مختلف الفرقاء المختلفين
ام ان الامر اه يعني اه مجرد تماهي بين اه
الخوف على المصير المصير الوطني وبين
مصالح دوليه مشتركه في محاربه عدو مشترك
اه ما يصطلح عليه بالارهاب
وشكلت هذه الحكومه بعدما اسقطت كل العقبات
التي كانت في الوجه اعتقد ايضا السؤال
سئلت ما هي كلمه السر كنت منها الخطر وفي
كل مره عندما ناس تشعر بالخطر نتجاوز
المتاريس التي مقرا وراءها هناك نقطه اريد
ان اشير اليها اقول ان لبنان قد تعرض
لحوادث ممثله في ثلاث محطات المحطات
الرئيسيه
المحطه الاولى كانت في الضمنيه عندما حاول
بعض المتطرفين الذين يدعون انهم ائمه
الاسلام ان يقيموا بؤره للتخريب والتكفير
تتصدى لها في ذلك الوقت الشهيد رفيق
الحريري واختها ووقف اه ب بصوره حازمه
وراء الجيش اللبناني الحادثه الثانيه في
عاده حكومه الرئيس فؤاد السنيوره
عندما جاء فتح الاسلام وجرب محاوله اخرى
في نهر البارد محبطه هذه المحاوله ووقف
الشعب اللبناني وراء الجيش وقفت الطائفه
السنيه وراء الجيش وذلك قراراتهم رئيس
الحكومه ودعم كامل من الرئيس سعد الحريري
اليوم يتكرر المشهد واذكر التصدي هذا يعني
ان هذا النبات الشيطاني الذي يحاولون ان
يزرع في هذه الطائفه لن يعيش لان حقيقه
هذه الطائفه لا تقبل الا المبادئ الصحي اه
ولكن اه هل هل اه هناك داخل الحكومه اجماع
كلي حول النظره الى كيفيه مقاربه منافع
ارسال كيفيه مقاومه
ال النازحين السوريين في لبنان
طلب منا دوله رئيس الحكومه اثناء ان هناك
الشعب الامس الام سرب ما يجري في الداخل
وذلك حفاظا على وحده الصف انا الان تتجاوز
قرار رئيس الحكومه واقول ان عشرين وزيرا
قد تحدثوا كل ربما لهجه مختلفه عن الاخر
ولكن ولكن ال المداخلات كلها كانت مدخلات
متكامله لم يفز لم نسمع صوت النافذه
الواحده كل الوزراء تحدثوا
بنبره ال الدعم الكامل غير المشروط للقوى
الامنيه والقوى الامنيه هي قوى تابعه
للشعب اللبناني بين الشعب اللبناني وتتلقى
الاوامر السياسيه من السلطه السياسيه
ولقد مارست السلطه السياسيه بالامس
صلاحياتها بجداره ت امها الشيخ
خليل الميس يعني اه اضافه لما قال السيد
رمان وقال السيد وزير يعني هناك نوع من
التقارب في وجهات النظر ولكن سؤالي هو كيف
يمكن ان نفهم اه ما صدر عن هيئه علماء
المسلمين حينما اتهمت من سمتهم متضررين من
مبادرتها للوساطه بالسعي الى السعي لتعطيل
هذه المبادره من هم هؤلاء
والله هو تسال الهيئه عن هذا اه اقول
لحضرتك شيء لان الذي اضطر هؤلاء اللجوء
الى لبنان معروفه جهه معينه كانها كان
هنالك فكره للمنازل على ارض ارسال ولكن
الله سلم الوطن وسلم ارسال بدخول الجيش
الموحد وال موحد والحقيقه كانت خطوه يعني
لقائد الجيش موفقه جدا جدا لان بدخول
الجيش تعود ارسال محظوره من الجيش الوطن
وتخرج البندقيه الوافده الى الخارج انه لا
يوجد طرف ثاني يقاتل
بارز على الساحه العاليه اذن بذلك يكون
جيش قوه الفرصه على كل الاخرين الذين
كانوا يريدون منازل على ارض ارسال
باختصار السيد الوزير في 10 ثواني ماذا لو
رفض المسلحون الانسحاب هذه الليله
بثمان
لهم الى بالانسحاب الجيش صارم في موقف
الحكومه الصارمه في موقفها نحن نعطيه
بالفرصه وعليهم ان ينتهزوا هذه الفرصه
ويجب انفسهم شكرا لك السيد الوزير رشيد
باس وزير الشؤون الاجتماعيه اللبناني من
بيروت شكرا ايضا اه الشيخ خليل الميس مفتي
زحله والبقاع منطقه البقاع ونشكر داوود
رمال اه الصحفي في جريده السفير اللبنانيه
بهذا تنتهي هذه الحلقه من برنامج ما شكرا
للمتابعه بشان الكرام والسلام عليكم ورحمه
الله وبركاته
ام